Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
declared that the case was closed on the
Moller report earlier this week but now
the Republican led Senate Intelligence
Committee has subpoenaed Donald Trump
jr. why President Trump responded
earlier today let's take a look my son
is a good person
my son testified for hours and hours
my son was totally exonerated by Muller
who frankly does not like Donald Trump
me this Donald Trump and frankly for my
son after being exonerated to now get a
subpoena to go again and speak again
after close to 20 hours of telling
everybody that would listen about a
nothing meeting
yeah I'm pretty surprised all right
joining us now with reaction is the
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
himself senator good to see you you have
called this partisan paralysis
breathless conspiracy theorizing
unhinged partisanship Groundhog Day a
spectacle stop REE litigating a
two-and-a-half-year-old election result
and move forward for the American people
I agree with all of that what is senator
Byrd doing did he not hear your message
well I think the good news is the
Chairman birdie and ik ated that the
committee will find no conclusion and no
collusion because that will be
consistent with the Muller investigation
I think this is gonna have a happy
ending I understand the president's
frustration here but I think this is
just a blip I think the case is closed I
think the controversy has been concluded
I don't think the house thinks that and
they're gonna continue to try to stir
this up but enough already I mean you
know we found out from the Muller report
that the Russians were deeply involved
in it there was something like 18 to 20
indictments of Russian companies and
Russian individuals who were trying to
get into the campaign and to mess with
it I think it's over and I think it's
time to let it go and move on
and try to deal with the people's
business specifically is that your
message to senator burr that's my
message to the public that's our view
that the case is closed and it's time to
move on and I believe when the Senate
Intelligence Committee finally does
report which I think will not be too far
down the road from here they'll reach
the very same conclusion you could you
called yourself the grin grim reaper
flooding concert when it comes to the
green New Deal
well I mean everything is going to be
for free so we're told but we're also
told that you can keep your your plan
and keep your doctor and save money that
didn't happen millions lost their plans
doctors and everybody paid more but this
see I think there's an important point
you're making this is not just
congresswoman Acacio cortes we've got
presidential candidates how do you was
how do you assess this group of 20-plus
Democrats that want to be president even
the ones Josh on that will declare
themselves moderates will say with
regard to health care that they want the
public option there won't be any private
health insurance if you have a public
option because the government will
always sell you the insurance cheaper so
no matter how they choose to
characterize themselves you can bet
whether it's Joe Biden Bernie Sanders or
somebody else the nominee for president
on the Democratic side is going to be on
a path to try to turn America into a
socialist country we're not gonna let
that happen
Donald Trump still in the White House
and as long as I'm majority leader of
the Senate I get to set the agenda
that's why I call myself the grim reaper
we will not have the green New Deal and
will not have Medicare for none as long
as I'm majority leader of the Senate
tell me about and tell us about your
relationship with the president now I
know you said we're not going to do
health care this year but I know most
Americans would like health care fix
they would like to have portability if
they change jobs I personally like
either health savings accounts there's a
health care cooperative where it's 50
bucks a month unlimited care and Wichita
Wichita Kansas dr. Josh Humber what it
what are the top agenda items as we
close out this year and move into
you know an election year well our
challenge in doing any kind of health
care reform now is the Democratic house
they're not going to agree to the kinds
of things we'd like to do that you
mentioned the president established this
the business to form small groups for
purposes of being able to allow groups
to purchase insurance like larger
companies and a number of other things
the administration's been trying to do
through executive orders but look you
know what the Democrats want to do their
run in the house they they want to have
Medicare for all which is actually
Medicare for none doing a deal with
Nancy Pelosi's house he's a real
challenge as the president's pointed out
on health care what he wants to do is to
come up with a recommendation we can
enact when we get the house back and
hold the Senate and he's in his second
term tell us about your relationship
with the president Trump how you work
together tell us maybe things you didn't
know about him that you now I assume you
talk with him regularly
tell us about yeah well we talk on
almost a daily basis we've been on the
same wavelength almost all the time
since he's been there we're trying to
take America in the same direction I
want to particularly compliment the
president for the extraordinary
selection he has made for judicial
appointments as you know Sean the
biggest call I made in my career was to
not let Barack Obama fill the Scalia
vacancy during the presidential election
I give you a lot of credit for that not
many times the president didn't blow
that opportunity he sent up Neal Gorsuch
and then we fought our way through a
highly controversial confirmation Brett
Kavanaugh but it's not just changing the
Supreme Court that we did we also are
changing the circuit courts one step
below the Supreme Court all right
senator thank you for being with us
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
we appreciate you taking time to be with
us tonight